hey guys it's justine and microsoft just
recently announced a new refresh to
their surface lineup they have a brand
new
surface laptop go which we have right
here and they also have some updates for
the surface pro x
but today we have the new surface laptop
go
to checkout this is the lightest most
affordable laptop
and comes in three different colors you
can configure these up to 16 gigs of ram
256 gigs of storage it has a 12.4 pixel
sense touch display
a fingerprint sensor to sign in 10th jet
intel core i5 processor
fast charging hd camera studio mics
precision track pad and up to 13 hours
of battery life
oh jenna said negative for covid oh my
god did we get our test back
i didn't get my i didn't get mine yet so
like if i have it like you're gonna
leave right now
honestly like this was so weird we drove
up did the thing
and then we put like our test sample
into like a big trash can
like it was tons of other tests our name
was just written on it in sharpie
i feel great i feel better than i have
in 20 years so
i'm just saying
oh this blue is so pretty
[Music]
oh super light
oh my god it's already turning on what
they're always on it's just freaking is
already like look at this
i touched nothing it doesn't really have
a smell wow this looks really good
the bezels are very small it has two
microphones up at the top to also
help with conference calls that's all
anybody ever does now this is already
signing up i haven't even opened up the
rest of my things yet
[Music]
that's it i'm cortana and i'm here to
help how many a little sign in here have
you guys touched your wi-fi there
watch me get your pc ready to do this
same setup i'm just wondering
a little sign in here a little sign in
there
this is how i dust it okay
we're gonna do fingerprint signum
we're gonna use our finger i can't talk
we're going to scan my finger
[Music]
check now out check me out oh it feels
so nice
it's a nice touch we are now all set up
this
color scheme of this laptop is really
really beautiful it's like a nice kind
of light blue they call it an ice blue
which i think is
pretty much a perfect name for it the
screen is
really really pretty the fact that
there's very small bezels there's a lot
of screen real estate inside of this
whereas i feel like a lot of laptops
especially this size and for this price
point
you usually will be losing a lot of
screen real estate and because of those
bezels
and hello touch screen let's go to a
website
oh yes here we go
this is my fresh new video that i just
posted on youtube i mean it looks really
good because like we shot it
so obviously you know look at our little
room this is where we are right now
that's i'm sitting right here the sound
let's see the sound let's turn these all
the way up we're shooting after the sun
went down we're like
really great in here we now have
controlled lighting i also have somebody
coming to paint this
wall let's listen to a royalty-free song
[Music]
i need some bass oh yeah
[Applause]
seems pretty solid for a very small
i don't even know where the speakers are
where are you
[Music]
it's a mystery oh here you are there you
are you're coming from inside here
sounds nice i mean obviously these
speakers are inside of a very small
little device i mean it's not going to
replace
some high quality headphones or speakers
but for what it is
i think they sound pretty good what i
really want to test out is
the camera on this we are now recording
let's act like we're on a conference
call okay hold on a second can everybody
hear me okay
can everybody hear me you can great okay
so today we're going to be discussing a
lot of very important matters the
matters
that matter are the ones that we're
going to be discussing and those are the
only ones that we're going to be
discussing does anybody
have any questions no great i'll see you
later
that's how the calls should go let's see
what we just made
we are now recording let's act like
we're on a conference call okay hold on
a second
um can everybody hear me okay can
everybody hear me
you can great okay so today i'm shocked
that sounds really
really good i feel like any time you're
recording on smaller laptops or devices
like this like the audio is not good
there's two
stereo microphones up here at the top
which i feel like really make a huge
difference
let me load up the xbox app and uh let's
see if we can play a game or two
i'm so hyped up about xbox game pass
i can play all of these game pass games
on any device i was just about to
install halo and i realized that these
laptops do come in s mode
which is great if you want to be very
secure and safe
and have microsoft kind of dictate what
you can install on this device
but i'm going to turn s mode off they do
give you a warning that says once you do
turn it off you can't turn it back on
you may want to think twice about
switching out of s mode especially
performance and peace of mind
are your top priorities i mean is peace
of mind ever my top priority
no so let's remove s mode and install
some games okay
so i'm testing out playing halo reach on
the surface
laptop go jenna you've been playing this
too i have i've been playing
what do you play minecraft dungeon this
is actually running surprisingly well i
mean because
this laptop isn't optimized for gaming
but guess what
i'm gaming fans are running a little bit
but
hi maddie do you want to come up here
buddy
no okay obviously if you're getting this
laptop this isn't going to be something
that you're buying for gaming
but you know just to be able to know
that it is able to handle some gameplay
it's getting the job done my my gaming
taste buds
have been quenched my gaming thirst
thirst thirsty for gaming oh man we're
in we are in
freaking battle now oh you guys are all
going this way it's fine oh no you're
not you're just slow
halo such a great game i can't wait
for halo infinite all right gaming test
is complete and guess what it was quite
successful
so that makes me really excited because
this is so
nice small light and compact that if i
am traveling
just to know that i'll be able to get my
gaming fix i'll be able to know and now
i know and now you know
i just want to give you guys a quick
look at the new surface go laptop i'm
such a huge fan of all of the things
surface so i'm excited to get a chance
to check this out and use this a little
bit more if you guys would like more
information i'll put a link in the
description and a huge thank you to
microsoft for sending me one of these to
check out and i will see you guys
in my next video bye
[Music]
you smell like a dirty dog
but a good smell